the Joe Rogan experience fun with it in
this fight like I said you know fifth
round I was ready and I said that for
the Romero fight and what's his name
Whitaker if I said look look how he
looked in the fifth round he's got gas
don't get me wrong he can be king crack
same people remember Romero and him they
don't have the same kind of spice as I
do when I'm in when I'm in the trenches
when it's time to go I can go because I
do it in the gym every day you wanted
Romero for your next fight sometimes man
I'm a shadow guy you know I mean he's
coming off three out of four losses
three in a row so I'm like yeah but all
of those could have been his yeah I know
but and also the people the people the
casuals they think this is the guy well
first of all I think Bronson was a guy
and then gasolin was a guy yeah and then
Whitaker's the guy said they think this
is the guy to beat me so I'm like all
right this is my charity work for the
year well he's an interesting fight for
anybody yeah hold up person says he's a
freak athlete I mean that you look up
freakin the dictionary you see picture
Yoel Romero flying through the air hit
and Chris Weidman with a new yeah I mean
he's just a freak I remember his first
fight I saw him he did the same thing to
the black guy bald black guy flying knee
boom and just kind of starched them just
for Anna Anna mmmm but this is leather
so what this is what Rises me to the
occasion this is one challenges me cuz a
guy like that like you say he's a beast
same thing or Robert he's a beast yep
but these levels to this and if you can
make that look easy it just makes you
look that like your status legendary
goat all that [ __ ] that's not you want
yeah so he wants nice looks good you
know I'm saying but it's all about the
the challenges taking out Robert
Whittaker in the second round in his
home country you know doing that to your
Romero maybe not in Cuba I don't know
what the situation is like there but
like in Vegas in a big arena TT mobile
arena that would be [ __ ] dope yeah
but the Dana say you know he's got to
get a win first their thing is they
don't know how to sell it like to the
people and I might [ __ ] it let's do it
anyway and I've said and leaving his
manager at the fights for whatever
reason while I was walking was I his
room we signed the contract I was like I
didn't know who it was
and say we signed the contract just tell
Dana I was like okay have my drink in my
hand walking like cool story bro we
signed the car
what the [ __ ] that Dinah's said this
yeah I was trying to say that's the hype
and then like right so on my the same
either said the video of him in the gym
saying Israel why are you back in now
why are you back it up you know just
tell they another [ __ ] day I'm like
but I'm like I want to do the fight I
said look this is a guy right this is a
yeah he's gonna take me down and beat
the [ __ ] out of me okay
no one's been able to do that yet so
let's see if this guy can do it let's
see if I can take him down well yeah the
thing is too you have to get him now yes
he's 41 now I think 40 41 he's oh yeah
that's what they're gonna say oh yeah
you beat open Europe he's still he was
when he fought Robert Whittaker they
didn't have that narrative no Pete
Whittaker I think the second time he'd
be with ya I said he dropped them yeah
he heard of that and and if you look at
those ten eight rules you know the the
new new rules he won yeah I look at you
you judging system yeah I thought he won
period I just thought he won yeah I mean
and Whitaker's a [ __ ] animal man he
hung in there with that guy blasting him
on the chin but he hurt him and he hurt
him bad several times but uh the pole
Acosta fight might get my guy a favorite
friend livin la vida Costa let's go
I felt like that that fight was legit
either one could have got that time I
think III agreed with it when Kosta
wanna up said okay I could see that but
if they gave it to Romero I would be
like why I could see that too I think
Austin won that fight like I said he
just stole it just oh yeah that's the
way to look at it just don't draw it
when he dropped him in the first round
that really solidified it and Romero was
trying his best to come back but just a
step behind in my eyes anyway like I
said if they roll the dice sometimes the
thing is shocking about Romero's how
well he takes it shot there's a picture
of Costa kicking him in the head that I
put on Instagram where it looks like his
soul is leaving his body like his eyes
are rolling back in his head that Shane
is wrapping around his head his whole
head is restored in Vegas the Jeff Lynch
saw those mics right yeah I just hold
his head in place hold his breath place
them just move well you know he had a
pretty severe neck in
if you look at the back of his neck he's
got a giant scar up his neck or a look
at his disks fused look at that picture
Dan why didn't know [ __ ] dude destroy I
sent his face into the [ __ ] black
hole of another universe yeah I mean
that is full impact that's turned the
hip on that yes it's all in Robert did
one on him as well but this is a lot
cleaner
yeah I'm nicer goddamn I mean he's he's
taking giant shots
I think Bronson hit him with a high head
kick as well wrapped around the neck
nothing I think his neck is like one
solid piece Yeah right [ __ ] they did in
Cuba to his neck when they did an
operation he's all fused up and he won't
cut it stiff you know I've seen him
around he's efficient when he's not
cutting away like he's a happy boy he's
Hugh but he's you know I can move before
y'all ready God he's real flexible I've
seen very flexing him doing the splits
hands on that dance on one clip did that
Cuban Olympic program is no joke I mean
when he described it he came on with
Joey Diaz and did you benefit yeah it
was amazing because Joey was translating
from Cuba to English and they were
talking about the program like they just
trained them and they put them in this
situation where if you win you get more
food and you get a better place to stay
and you get two meals a day if you lose
you get three meals a day if you win and
these guys are there competing it's the
best in the world
yeah and it's just every day is battle
battle you know it's like everybody
always wants to kill me and you become
on my team like you know and you see the
dude first of all when you're sitting
across from me like okay with you I know
you're heavier than 185 pounds but it's
feasible
[Applause]